getting things done isn't working all
day at 100 miles an hour looking for
ways to do less and get more dong signs
a bit counterintuitive but it actually
makes a lot of sense and the following
tips can definitely help you suppose
you've got a really important
presentation today it's the kind of task
productivity expert professor Kyle
Newport says needs deep work deep work
is your concentration sweet spot where
you can achieve most smaller tasks like
answering emails are shallow work try to
be more conscious of what your shallow
tasks are and give yourself permission
to block them out for a while so you can
focus on the important tasks that
require deep work lots of successful
people have caught out the shallow to
work more productively
Bill Gates went to a remote cottage
others like Maya Angelou shut themselves
away to write for good productivity be
strict about when you're working day is
over and when you get to the end of your
planned work session ease yourself into
a more relaxed feel and try calm
Newport's shot dine ritual look through
your unfinished work write a short plan
of how you'll tackle it tomorrow then
close that tax book or laptop and say
something out loud like shot down
complete it might sound silly but it
signals the end of your working thoughts
and for the day after that have some fun
give your mind the rest it's earned
businessman Warren Buffett's technique
for getting people to focus on their
most important goals was simple write
down in order the top 20 things you want
to do in life and then draw a line under
number 5 until you've done those first 5
forget everything else for a more
structured approach organize your
priorities by making a pyramid of goals
designed by psychologist professor
Angela Duckworth find the big thing that
we could call your life's purpose like
inspiring others or helping people and
society
put that at the top on the next level
you'll have mid-level goals like passing
an exam the goals below it should all
feed into your top level
there'll be smaller more practical
things perhaps write in an email or
doing some research if they don't help
with achieving your top goal then get
rid of them you can make a similar
pyramid with a more specific task at the
top like that big presentation remember
all the other two do's should feed in
let's get back to the big presentation
it'll take a few hours to get it done
properly but in order to keep those
stress levels at bay
try the Pomodoro Technique knee and
after a tomato shaped kitchen timer time
management guru Francesco Cirillo says
that for every 25 minutes of intense
concentration you should take five off
to do nothing at all
the theory tackling a big task and
focused chunks with regular bricks gives
the Berean time to recover and keeps
your productivity high in a five-minute
breaks don't jump on your phone move
around stare out of a window a recent
study showed that regular five-minute
walk breaks improves people's mood and
even make them feel less tired and
hungry at work and finally if you really
need the concentrate find some pictures
of kittens and puppies first that's
right research in Japan suggests that
looking at cute baby animals brings out
the natural caregiver in us and improves
our ability to focus on the details
turns out productivity can be cute too
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon